[Music]
so there's finally an update
let's find an update on something
windows 9
very good
i'll read it uh relating to the uh
brianna taylor raid actually
yeah
federal officials have finally charged
four officers in the briana taylor right
is that when they went to the house um
yeah
yeah yeah and then they there's camera
footage right and then they went in
and then they uh
i'm just trying to recap the audience
for people that don't remember
through the wall
uh and uh she unnecessarily died
through the killing the cops did a
drive-by they did they did they did do a
drive-by federal officials on thursday
charged four current and former police
official uh officials officials i like
officials
in louisville kentucky
who were involved in a fatal raid on the
apartment briana taylor accusing them of
several crimes including lying to obtain
a warrant that was used to search her
home
that's the interesting thing
how did they lie what was the lie do you
know
um
they say we got a warrant or they they
lied and got away you get the warrant
from the judge so they like to the judge
then uh so during the nighttime raid in
march 2020 officers knocked down the
door and fired a volley of gunshots
after miss taylor's boyfriend shot an
officer in the leg believing that
intruders had burst into the home whoa
two officers shot miss taylor a 26 year
old emergency room technician who was
pronounced dead at the scene jesus
christ attorney general merrick garland
said at a news conference that the
louisville officers had quote violated
federal civil rights laws and that those
violations resulted in miss taylor's
death
it was like um
the wrong house or something right like
that they were going for yeah so like um
her boyfriend was shooting quote unquote
in self-defense and ended up shooting a
police officer because well that's
because they thought they were being
broken into they didn't know it was cops
yeah the cops did a no-knock warrant
that's the most [ __ ] up part about the
whole thing so you just kick the door
down yeah they're not declaring that
they're cops and that they are coming in
or anything and they have a warrant
they're just opening the [ __ ] door
and coming in i mean even then if like
if it really was cops and they came in
that way how are you supposed to believe
in that quickly
i don't know how are you supposed to i
just started shooting a computer yeah
like process too it's like the middle of
the night if the door busted down [ __ ]
i'm not gonna say i hope you guys are
officers and weren't they actually
trying to go after her ex or something
that was like they thought he was like
dealing out of that home or some [ __ ]
they were watching her that's what it
was like it wasn't he wasn't even there
the guy that was a target right yeah
they were watching that place for like a
month i think damn one thing they
couldn't get a warning i don't know
jesus so the killing of miss taylor who
was black helped to set off protests in
the spring and summer of 2020 following
the police killing of george floyd in
minneapolis and led to intense scrutiny
of the police department in louisville
the justice department has been
investigating the department and the
county government for more than a year
reviewing whether officers regularly use
unreasonable force and whether officers
who break the department's rules are
held accountable
neither of the officers who shot and
killed miss taylor have ever been
charged nor are they named in the new
indictments
the charges instead name three officers
who were part of an investigative unit
that obtained the search warrant for the
raid along with the fourth officer who
was later fired from the department
because officials said he had fired
blindly into miss taylor's apartment and
struck a neighboring apartment damn well
you're shooting like this and [ __ ] he
had this spread fire going from contra
and he was just [ __ ] that's a good
that's a sick power up though in that
game man
that former officer brett hankerson
already faced state criminal charges in
the case the only charges filed over the
raid until thursday but was acquitted
the new indictment accuses him of
federal civil rights violations
ever since uh like uh george floyd
though like i'm starting to finally see
a lot of cops
get in trouble for misconduct before
this it was always all you know
we're looking we're looking into it and
uh you know uh they're on paid leave
right now we're gonna show them we're
going to show them the body cam footage
malfunctioned yeah that's a classic line
that's the number one yeah or the ones
where it's like hey turn your camera off
turn the camera off yeah that one like
jesus internal first stacked with x cops
too like who went up the chain so it's
like they're trying to protect the thin
blue line at all times yeah so it's like
cool thanks for the no bias
so the bulk of the charges and the
latest indictments surround the search
warrant that police officer had sought
in an investigation of miss taylor's
former boyfriend whom they had believed
to be selling drugs like ryan said
prosecutors said on thursday that two
detectives and a police sergeant had
falsely claimed in an affidavit used to
obtain the warrant that the foreign
boyfriend had been receiving packages at
mrs taylor's apartment
in fact according to the indictment the
officers had no evidence of such
packages but misrepresented their case
to the judge who authorized the raid
that [ __ ] was a big that was a really
big piece of the element of the story so
that part wasn't even true holy [ __ ]
they [ __ ] up so hard one of the
officers charged joshua james a former
detective who was also fired over his
role in the raid sent a draft of the
affidavit to kelly goodlett another
detective now facing charges in which he
included the false claim about the
package as the prosecutor said
miss goodlatte knew that the claim was
false the prosecutor said but did not
object to it and also added what they
described as a quote misleading claim
that the former boyfriend was using the
address to miss taylor's apartment as
its current address dude the fact that
you can
you can lie and then the person that
you're lying to is like got it thank you
we'll we'll keep the lie up the chain
let's go [ __ ] it
like present the evidence to get the
warrant and there wasn't the third
officer charged sergeant kyle
meaney
what a mini who led a department
investigative unit approved the
affidavit despite knowing that it
contained the false information damn
everyone looked the other way all of the
chain
i wonder how often this happens all
right very often probably just in this
case
yeah probably probably just louisville
kentucky yeah the indictment accuses two
of the officers not only of including
false information in the affidavit but
conspiring to lie about it afterwards
that's crazy two months after miss
taylor's death prosecutors said miss mr
james and miss good at good luck met in
mr jane's garage and decided to tell
investigators falsely
that a sergeant had informed them that
packages were being sent to mrs taylor's
apartment
that is so many behind-the-back punches
in order to [ __ ] clear up their story
together
mr james and mr meaney were each accused
of violating ms taylor's right to be
free from unreasonable searches and
seizures miss goodlett was accused of
conspiring to falsify the affidavit as
well as conspiring to hinder the
subsequent investigation into the raid
mr mr james was also charged with
conspiring to hinder the investigation
how many [ __ ] times do you think
they've done this where it's protocol
and so many people have been wrongly
yeah accused or or uh uh caught or like
whatever i hate to think about it but
probably a lot it's probably one of
those things where they've actually
caught the right guy this way so many
times too yeah that they're like oh
let's just let it yeah you know because
sometimes they do actually catch the
right guy and sometimes the right guy is
is so legislatively illiterate that he's
just like oh you got me yeah you know
where like some people are like
more like easy to find the holes in the
system
this is why i'm so scared of the death
penalty and i always like yo i'm against
the death penalty because of [ __ ] like
this like they can lie about you they
can arrest you they can throw you in
prison and you have no recourse so at
least maybe if you're in prison there's
a there's a hope that someday somebody
will help to find your innocence but
that's true the idea that we're just
going to close the book on you because
we got it all figured out already yeah
when [ __ ] like this is happening all the
time that's definitely the best argument
against the death penalty yeah
the incompetence of the government
exactly all the lies and the lies and
it's like you're leaving your your fate
in the hands of these people that are
potentially gonna lie on you and that's
like that's also speaking for most cases
that don't get media attention like some
dude could get arrested
go to the death penalty die and no one
knew one thing about them absolutely
that's it they'll find out from dna
evidence later if they didn't have like
friends or family fighting for them or
anything like that too you know because
yeah or they didn't have stephen avery's
like fan base stephen avery you guys
think he did it 100 no way
100 no way well until i saw season two
and i was like oh that's interesting
now i'm waiting for season three to know
what i think what about brandon though
what about what what about brendan
that's he didn't do a thing dude brandon
dassey just seems too [ __ ] dumb i
think i got worse than him they're for
sure close careers that's what i thought
when i was watching season one and this
is making making making a murderer yeah
season two did you wanna just throw you
for a loop a little stephen avery
probably did it
he probably bread and dassey probably
didn't do it as what i thought and then
i started watching season two i was like
maybe he probably what do they say in
season two i don't even remember bob
bernadzy yeah
he was he was trying to watch
wrestlemania a lot of people's opinions
changed once they got to the part where
steven avery like burns a cat alive he
burned a cat a lot remember when there's
like yeah i didn't say it yeah so like
there's like most people that do [ __ ]
like that
could probably kill a dude you know what
i mean like don't [ __ ] i know that got
you yeah
well that's why they say like sometimes
cops
become a little bit gray area because
they know that this [ __ ] is wrong
exactly they just finish up and make it
more solid right because they don't want
the stupid like court system yeah to
kind of you know the red tape stupid
[ __ ] you gotta cut through the red
tape sometimes well it's evidence we
don't need evidence all the time and
they're gonna do what they think you
don't know like when you get pulled over
for [ __ ] and they'll live like can you
still you know like most times you don't
have to step out of your car you don't
have to open your trunk you don't want
to open your hood you don't have to
they're gonna damage
but if they say hey open your hood then
you're gonna [ __ ] do it because
you're just like oh [ __ ] i better do it
and then there's a whole bunch of
[ __ ] drugs and money you're like you
weren't even supposed to do that [ __ ]
man that's out of bounds oh man if they
open my head i'm like sure it's just a
[ __ ] engine i'm not an idiot it's in
my trunk
if i
it's in the upholstery [ __ ] to open
your trunk that's sexual harassment whoa
what do you mean by that damn so i like
where this video started we were like
yeah [ __ ] these cops but now we're kind
of like okay this is uh maybe we should
have some cops who cut cut through the
red line right joe
sometimes boy i'm glad joe made that
point hey i don't know about you but i'm
for the death penalty always was on you
know i just feel like it's the greatest
thing in the world but um that's the
greatest thing you know what i mean
why why yeah
people shouldn't exist sometimes oh i
see
people yeah
and then like if they're getting caught
up in the system then you know exist
sometimes a lot of people do you believe
in having like a purge day oh a thousand
percent we should have more purge days
more um more more more than just one i
mean it kind of exists right now in
downtown l.a and you know but like
chicago yeah chicago
yeah
i don't know but i feel like it's kind
of unfair for people that are poor
because they live in purge day every day
and it's kind of like that's our that's
out of bounds right there you know it
should be one
day so they should get purge day off
they actually should yeah i think so
they should we should have like purge
like
free zones people trying to purge them
isn't that the whole thing i don't think
if joe was the leader of the world it
would be so confusing
i think i'd be so confused if joe was a
leader it would make sense when you're
there it's one of those things where you
got to be in it to understand the vision
there's like there's a lot of things
that are lost in translation you know
there's like culture there's like so
many new cultures you know like it's
hard to explain but you got to be there
you know and then you gotta live it and
then you're like ah
it's like kim jong jitsukawa kim jong ji
we have to kill this goddamn fly the fly
is definitely ruining things it's right
next to you i mean it does exist right
that's what jamali is yeah well i want
to honeypot his sister and then take
over the country
kim jong-il
she's very by the way ass [ __ ]
she's fine bro that's a confirmed hot
system dude [ __ ] kim jong-il's sister
man like you think kim jong-il got like
hots for assists he's like yo sis you
look crazy dude do you think they would
ever have north korean pop
they should like as a popular one what
would it be see those [ __ ] dudes with
the accordion bands they got like 50
guys on accordion that [ __ ] would be
yeah
that is fine bro
you literally
you said kim jong-il's sister no oh no
oh that's the ceo of [ __ ] kumon
he knew come on
talking about it
[Laughter]
you wished
she owns a seafood city market
yo that's that's a mitsuba owner
man you know what my type is what
powerful women [ __ ]
i like a strong woman like
this is not steve's sister quality dude
that's awesome
kindergarten teacher she is the
right-hand woman of the most powerful
man with the biggest military in the
world
yeah watch your [ __ ] south korea has
the biggest so that's what makes your
hot
power makes people hot
foreign